what is up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Fantastic
Fest 2023 I have more of the filmmakers
behind VHS 85 congratulations on your
movie thank you absolutely adored it
loved it every single segment in it a
plus I have one unrelated question that
I have to throw your way Gigi because we
went to the debates the other night I
came here this is my first fantastic one
I was very excited to see the debates
now I want to participate giving you
ours I don't want to fight you though oh
so don't did you see my smile I was like
finally don't fight next year so I can
fight but what would you what would be
like your pointers your tips and tricks
for someone who is about to get into
that ring for the very first time yeah I
mean definitely have as much alcohol
before
and definitely because you gotta be in a
really good mood to get in there and
I think the debates is the thing that
helps you test your improv skills and
test your comeback skills and your
street smart smart skills and your anger
skills and you see like how much passion
you get gets shown in that ring these
are all things I need to work on so
maybe
yeah she asked me to fight her
I said no she straight up said no I'm
not trying to get my ass beat in a room
full of my professional peers one of the
things I stress about with that idea is
I don't know if I could actually punch
someone I like so they and like I feel
like I like everyone here like who would
they find that I would be willing to
punch it's true in the years before that
I've been asked to do the debates it was
always someone I liked and but but
things change
things change when you're in character
and things change when like the insults
start to happen you become someone else
okay you know but like uh at this year's
debate I did not know my opponent at all
so it was a lot of fun just hearing and
and for the first time what they had to
say made it easy not to make this whole
thing about the debates but I will say
she held her own again she's amazing
incredibly well and also she had an
impossible side of that debate for this
crowd and she she crossed crushed it I
was terrified I I've been sharing it
with everybody I felt like a little a
little Mario fighting Bowser nothing was
beating her down yeah nothing she didn't
feel any hits I kept hitting and hitting
and she kept coming
just like how Bowser does it and she
just kept charging what's what's the
Mario equivalent to you like punching me
and me just blacking out right from the
start whatever that character is that's
what I would like my pitch was that it
should be all the other VHS filmmakers
versus GG and then it'll be a fair fight
you know I I think that's great that
would be what I would show up to watch
that channel
and then Dave goes this is just a
brilliant idea you should actually pitch
this
let's talk about your actual movie right
now I have a question for all three of
you to start because one of my favorite
things about the VHS movies is it feels
like these producers get a bunch of
filmmakers with unique voices and then
support them to the point that not only
can they maintain their voice but they
could bring the absolute best out of
their work so can you tell me something
about the producing team behind this
movie that helped you deliver your best
work I mean okay I'll just start at the
beginning
um getting that call
was awesome uh I think we can all kind
of share in that a little bit but like
this was uh I mean we all love VHS and
um that was sort of like the they uh
David I always calls it this this moves
are punk rock man and so VHS was like
the punk rock
um uh found footage thing and you can
tell by watching all of them that every
single filmmaker is having a blast
because they just let them loose and so
to be a part of that
um was kind of like a dream like oh man
that'd be so cool some days like I can
do I can do shorts I can do some gnarly
[__]
um this would be fun I have ideas and
then
um
I met Josh Goldblum uh at uh sin
apocalypse I premiered a film there
called the domestics and
um you know stay in touch with him for a
little bit but then didn't hear from him
over covid and then suddenly
what's up bro
um and uh you you you wanna get on a
call and I was like
oh my God please this this could be this
could be good this could be no no no no
way he's just calling to see how things
are going Josh is it great Josh is nice
guy
so man I'm looking for directions for
VHS and like shut up you know it was
just one of those things where you're
just like oh my god um yeah and uh being
able to pitch
um the team and them being excited about
hearing that pitch and then being like
okay I'm I'm doing this
um and then again to then be given like
go
um let us know what you need to support
you and we will do the best we can and
make make cool stuff
makers that's what we live for is for
that sort of creativity and so yeah
incredible and I mean being teamed up
with this
is these amazing like being beside these
filmmakers is kind of like what's hap
what is happening right now yeah it's
really cool yeah yeah I was brought in
by Dave Bruckner initially
um and it was very casual conversation
and uh he introduced the the you know
for the context he basically said just
think of it as a [__] you movie and that
really uh resonated with me and spoke to
me
um
I I think um first of all what we do as
directors is very solitary you know like
I I come from crew and
um I think I really miss that uh that
that group
Project Feel of you know I used to be in
camera department and you know you kind
of have your team of people and all that
kind of stuff but there's one director
usually
um so I think being able to work with
these incredible people you know
peripherally but still it felt like
we're like okay we're all we're kind of
doing a thing together that's kind of
cool
um you know I didn't even meet Mike
until you were in your mix but I knew
what you were doing we had we heard
about each other you know we're like oh
Scott's doing this there's a mysticism
behind what
yeah real humans but but also like I
think it coming together in that really
beautiful or beautiful organic way um as
a group was really fun so so that was
really special
um and then I would also say like we we
work within extremely strict and you
know Gigi and I talk about this a lot
um just we're kind of working within the
confines of the industry which is you
know it purports to be a creative
industry but in fact is is you're kind
of creating a product right and we are
sort of the we we are like birthing from
product to creativity back to product
um and I think to have something that is
a [__] you movie it was so liberating
and joyous even though I was very scared
of the found footage of it all in the
beginning
um you know that that is it's a simple
thing to say but to actually be able to
experience it is a truly truly truly a
gift so I'm very grateful to be a part
of it beautiful answer happy for you GJ
I kidnapped everyone to let me be part
of it
um no I'm King no no
listen I think my experience was a
little different but just to add to to
theirs as well I think all of us can say
that we grew up watching
five of these this is the sixth one of
VHS and getting the opportunity to be
part of the cool kids club is for all of
us like that hardcore like whoa I made
it I'm here and so so for me it was
something I just always wanted to maybe
not be part of the Anthology but since
VHS 2 watching it in film school I was
like one day I want to be just friends
with these guys I want to be part of
that and uh so my experience I I didn't
get an invite or a call I just crashed
their set on 99. I I legit just showed
up because I Gotta Give it to Cargill
who wrote with Scott dreamkill he called
me knowing I was in LA and said you're
in L.A right I was like yes also why are
you calling me this is cool and he let
me know so you know we've shot our VHS
yes there's a new one coming out and I'm
here to tell you there's space for one
more and it has to be you you and that
meant the world to me that he he said
that to me and he told me like a true
Jefe that he is how did make that happen
he said go to Burbank meet Josh Goldblum
the producer just show up they're
shooting the one now and just go tell
them that it has to be you and I I show
I went straight to their set and knocked
on the door like how Indie filmmakers do
it yeah that's punk rock yeah
it's totally how you do it and I showed
up Josh was like uh sure come to the set
what do you got I'm like
I don't know what what do you got huh
what date do you got and as soon as he
told me 85 I said I'll come back
tomorrow and I showed up the next day
with an idea so it was super cool was
that the I I'll go down the row again
for each of your individual shorts was
that idea the idea we now see in the
final film correct not early as soon as
he's at 85 uh I I left the set gave him
a big hug and said thank you and I
immediately called my my best friend
Raynor who's produced everything I've
done I'm like 85 it has to be Mexican yo
what do we do and he he's the one that
actually said to me well the earthquake
in Mexico City and I remember having
that gasp reaction because I know what
it's like I my whole family lived it
it's the biggest fear in the city
I was like there's no brainer but we're
gonna put that GG twist at the end yeah
I'm saying you know what I'm saying so
it just was a no-brainer it was very
very it was all twist this is something
I'm always curious about with found
footage movies I'll throw it your way
just because it feels like you have more
movement maybe than anyone else does in
their shorts but when you're designing
your shots what is the key to making
sure it does have like an authentic
found footage feel where it does feel
like someone's holding the camera and
running but while ensuring that the
audience does not get dizzy and has a
sense of geography is that such a man
that's uh that's a question we can talk
about for hours yeah but like for hours
hours because there's tons of techniques
that we will find ourselves that is so
different from each other but I can tell
you that in mind specifically was
completely feeling organically the
emotions of the cast and feeling what is
adrenaline rush to survive because mine
was very inspired by wreck it's real
time there's no there's no moment in
time there's no space later it's just a
one time only
so for the camera it really was
who's reacting and it if you're the
cameraman how do you react to the
situation what are you going to want to
film or maybe are you distracted but the
thing is filming something that you're
not looking at so it was a lot of
feeling the cast and it was our
cinematographer holding the camera while
being hugged by the lead actor to just
feel his energy and how he would react
to who is talking would make our
cinematographer move the camera so
that's how we did it uh just to just to
feel the energy of how tragic it is oh
god it feels like such a warm loving way
to make such a horrific short film
definitely
um emphasizing the actors I'll go to you
now Natasha because it does feel like
your your idea needs a Pitch Perfect
lead performance or it doesn't work and
I believe you've worked with Siobhan
before right Siobhan is one of my
collaborators yeah I love her
exceptional what is something about your
previous collaborations that signal to
you should be perfect in the role but
then also I want to know something she
did while shooting that made you go like
damn we know each other but I never even
realized you were capable of that yeah
Siobhan is a really interesting actor
because on the one hand she's incredibly
beautiful
um very polished and so she will often
get cast as you know this you know
perfect stunning gorgeous model-esque
you know um and we really wanted to go
the opposite direction with this you
know because performance art gets mean
it gets dirty it gets um raw
um and and she actually I think was that
was the part she was the most
um freaked out about and so the
performance is very influenced by um
work of artists
um from the era but also a lot of the
work that my own mother did as I was
growing up so it was like sort of a love
letter in some ways to those real people
who were doing that work and you know
like raised me in a lot of ways but uh
we watched a lot of actually my mom's
old archival
um archival videos of her performances
you know she's like getting naked on
stage like there's my mom
um
uh but but Siobhan really um she she had
I think some intense conversations with
with my mother and about sort of like
vulnerability and how do you um you know
feel the confidence and stuff and I
think my mom just said like Oh no you're
you leave your body she's like no no
you're you're you're performing a seance
like you are traveling to another
dimension you know this shamanistic
performances that these people were
doing at the time
um so yeah I think that was really fun
for me to see Siobhan she's a very
classical you know she's Shakespeare
she's very polished and uh you want to
know her lines before and she wants
everything to be perfect I'm like no no
it's a performance we wrote a
performance see this part where it says
she performs the incantation that's a
that's a three minute sequence and
that's all you baby girl we set up
Mike's for her she was doing we taught
her how to
um we were doing live Distortion so the
film is a live performance that we
archived basically so including we made
a bunch of samples for her that she was
manipulating live so a lot of the
effects and uh you know two mics that
were sort of interacting with each other
so she really had to learn a lot of
these sort of avant-garde in the 80s
techniques um and yeah she got she got a
little she got a little messy so was it
a situation where your audience was
actually seeing what she was doing in
the room
um for parts of it yeah for parts of it
we did have a whole day that was just
her and I mean I was in the audience
because it's found footage so I was like
I'm gonna sit here I happen to know
someone else in your audience and I'll
always take an opportunity to shout out
Andrew guy because he is
what what kind of direction do you give
your audience members so they could at
least start to picture the wild things
so they did have her sorry I understand
your question now yes so um they did
have her so we shot them on the last day
so she could kind of relax I think she
performed it in sweatpants or something
but she's she gave him a show so that's
all right that's all there that's real
live reaction and I basically just told
them uh it's they're all actors because
we shot in LA
but uh but yeah I just said you know
this is this is uh I just experience it
just experience it react as you would
react you know don't hold back
um and yeah she did she did give them a
live show so yeah I'm gonna squeeze in
one more question stop me if it gets a
little too spoilery maybe but can you
tell us anything about the evolution of
the design of your your demon is that
what it looked like in your head day one
when you started picturing this idea or
is that something that changed well I
always knew she was female
I always knew that she was going to be a
lady God
um and uh and Fierce and more like
um and and humanoid but not entirely
humanoid
um so we did a lot of early concept art
I kind of wanted to also give Siobhan a
mental image of what she was seeing
um because she was acting against
um a blank screen so that was all
created after the fact
um but yeah it was it was honestly I
have to also not to to David
um who was very involved creatively with
with really pushing us and pushing and
pushing and it's it's kind of rare to
find a creative producer who is truly
creative
um and so I really appreciate being
pushed because we would kind of come to
the table and be like we like this
this is finished question mark I say no
it's not go back to the driver okay okay
so we go back and we just kept pushing
and making her dirtier and raw and um
you know but yeah we started with I know
she's female I know she's she's tall
she's like 12 feet tall in the virtual
world and
um we kind of uh developed her from
there but I like her a lot so so
effective I love her already and I want
people should have a wedding isn't it
interesting that our pieces are so I
mean it's a summoning it's like we we're
bringing these these Gods back which I
think is there's something kind of cool
about that there is um there is like in
addition to the wraparound at least it
does feel like there is connective
tissue even though we each short in this
movie feels so uniquely your own which I
appreciate Mike for years now you were
talking a little bit about when you
first joined the project when you first
signed on did you know you'd have the
opportunity to like essentially make two
yeah so that was that was kind of part
of the pitch
um I knew that I wanted to have these
two cases that felt very different the
the first part I had very very clearly
in my head the second part was kind of
like I was figuring it out I knew I
wanted to go
um I knew they wanted I wanted to I
don't want to get too spoiled early but
like I wanted to have some sort of a a
Revenge payoff but I wasn't quite sure
what that was and I knew I really wanted
it to feel completely different so again
you did feel like here's the next
segment
um and when I pitched that to David and
Josh and Brad they were all kind of like
oh yeah that's that's cool like Let's do
let's go
um and so that was that was fun to
figure out and then fun to kind of
discover like to do something against
against the norm of like
what you would expect
that killer to be and do you know what I
mean and what and what they're a part of
so
um lots of lots of fun exploration there
and uh yeah yeah okay I have a like a
broader found footage question for you
that's nice and safe before I ask one
that might view too close to spoiler
territory when you have a group of
friends who essentially get picked off
one by one what is it like figuring out
the perfect camera person the perfect
Storyteller for that story
um that's a great question yeah that's
that's that's really good
um I knew I wanted so our segment sort
of has this like it's like there's like
a very kind of a light love story in it
um like like new love like meeting
somebody or maybe somebody that you've
known briefly but like kind of like
Smitten by and I wanted to be on the
side of the camera I wanted I wanted the
cameraman to be the one who's sort of
like
um spitting by this this this girl and
how it doesn't look like it's gonna work
out
um but they end up kind of like you know
hitting it off and it's and it's fun
like like the to me it was like the the
whole like um the the camera hand up do
you want to try like that to me was like
a really sweet moment and I really
wanted to build this sort of like that
sort of um
um uh character with with the cameraman
and uh with Rob
um Robin
um and uh and let that kind of Blossom
throughout the movie up until when she
you know takes the chance to to go
skiing and he's just he's kind of yeah
you got this come on it's so good and
you end up really
um it was important to me to
um enjoy being with these people sort of
like you were with a group of friends
you're not with a um a dysfunctional
group of friends which I feel like is
such an easy thing to fall into in
horror where you just you kind of hate
everybody and you're kind of just you're
waiting for each person to get picked up
it's it's far worse to like feel either
even even to feel neutral because you
you're like okay whatever yeah these
people are fine and then to see
something terrible happen to them
because you're like
none of them deserve any of this right
now and so and that's and that's the
point you know what I mean the point is
is that something bad could happen at
any moment and I think we're living in a
time where that's very very true yes
that element of it did freak me out
quite a bit so this is the question that
we get a little spoilery but I am often
mesmerized by the Artistry that goes
into Gore and makeup effects so can you
maybe give us one non-spoiler example of
something you did on set in that respect
at least that made you think like I
cannot believe this is what it takes to
make it look like that on screen in the
finished product I mean so much of it is
like okay so it's
it starts by again like having like the
uh the dream case scenario where you're
like okay
I know that this is what's going to
happen
um
I go to my special effects guy uh Ryan
shadley who's you know Minnesota native
for both minnesotans he's an incredible
uh special effects makeup Prosthetics
designer and I'm like so this is this is
what I want to do and I don't want it to
look trashy I don't want it to look
um exploitive I don't want it to be like
you know I let's let's go like
um
yeah let's go let's try to make this is
kind of real and and in a way kind of
icky as possible and I was like because
I really don't want to do this digitally
and I know that that's this could be a
tall order but I need you to tell me
no because this is what I want and he
goes
oh yeah we can do that
um and again like I don't want to get
into what what that is because I think
it's once you watch the movie you'll
you'll know what that moment is and that
was
um it was challenging but uh super
rewarding because again on camera
effects when you're there with everybody
um everybody's experiencing it
everybody's reacting to it and you just
like you feel it's it's a it's
electrifying it's there's energy you're
just like oh my God this is this is
happening Things Are
it takes more time sure but in the end
totally totally worth it it's excellent
yeah really really really A Plus job
every single shot in that respect I
loved it all right I'm gonna end with
one broader fantastic fast question for
all of you because again this is my
first year and I've heard about this
here but feeling it is something
different it basically being an
environment of horror lovers people in
the community that aren't just here to
enjoy films but also to uplift each
other so can you tell me something you
saw in someone else's film here that you
thought was incredible and has now
inspired you and maybe you'll carry it
forward to your next project I really
enjoyed the shorts box
um I I think uh I don't expose myself to
shorts as much as I should
um and I there was one block in
particular that was uh indigenous voices
short
um that I I thought was really kind of
beautiful to see the diversity within
that category and with the shorts
program a lot of younger you know a lot
of like emerging filmmakers and stuff
um so I always find that kind of
exciting to see
um who's out there who's sort of like
dipping their toe into directing and
filmmaking
um so yeah I really enjoyed actually the
the shorts I mean of course the features
are fabulous but I'm always here for
shorts right yeah those programs never
get the credit they deserve they were
cool yeah I really enjoyed it yeah I
watched um
stop motion and
um yeah I mean it's great because like I
I love I'm a huge fan of um
the Slow Burn that turns into something
gross you know what I mean because when
you start with gross
where do you go from there you know what
I mean because then it's kind of like
well
I mean I feel like we've been witnessing
this for 90 minutes now and you really
have to do something
you know to to kind of beat you're
almost you're almost you're upping
yourself throughout but again uh what
was really great about stop motion was
it did kind of have this uh a little bit
of a shining Vibe
um where it's this woman who's kind of
losing herself in this stop-motion work
which gets really really like icky and
then finally what she ends up doing
you're just like
like I I haven't I haven't squirmed at
something uh really recently and like
it's not even that it was that gory per
se but it's the actions and the things
that she does that were that were like
you know you're just like okay
[Music]
the blade is getting closer to the leg
CL okay yep yep here it is
um yeah and I want to see this movie
it's really good yeah it's it's you can
tell you can tell there's there was just
there was a lot of care there's a lot of
thought and um I really again I really
appreciate that when like a filmmaker
will take their time and let you just
get in and then finally just say
yeah and he was like stop God damn it
you know what I mean like it's and so
and they and they did it and they did it
and and and and that was really fun very
appropriate description of that movie
right there yeah and I gotta see that
yeah it's wonderful
you know I can talk about many of the
films I've seen here but this is my
fifth year back I've been back with uh
three features I've been back past the
shorts jury uh my first year here was
was my short film El higante and
I just gotta say it's it's not even just
one film in particular it's the festival
itself I really say that from the bottom
of my heart to the people who put this
Festival together it is so perfectly
organized in the way that this is the
place
it's not just genre films it's easy to
say that it's where you're gonna see
from bizarre to so much heart to the
absolute most disturbing you're gonna
see a rainbow of weird in this festival
and you're also going to see so many
familiar faces coming back coming back
you're gonna see true fans of Cinema
true fans of genre and all the
filmmakers always come back here
everybody comes back here because
it's very welcoming and it's only at a
place like fantastic Fest like the Alamo
that is a very particular Festival that
is only to go see movies you go to
festivals I hate to say it just to go
party and have your Premiere and that's
where it ended for your film if you have
time for seeing something else great but
this is curated that from the morning to
the night is movies back to back and you
get a chance to see them a second time
so you come here to watch what you don't
go see in the theater you come here to
watch movies that push boundaries movies
that
get tiny distributions because of how
odd they are you come here to see things
that are not commercial and it's there's
a film for everybody at the end of each
year that I've been back and I gotta say
this year it was still amazing how many
people remember my short film uh that's
not it's not happened to me in any other
festival that they're like I remember
you're short from seven years ago when
are you gonna hear that so it's that's
the praise I have to give oh and what a
perfect place to to Premiere this movie
right like 100 this is a whack like this
is not necessarily what I would describe
as broad appeal film but to see it in
the in the theater completely come alive
like a film doesn't come to life until
it's in the theater and shared with
other people so I think for all of us to
finally like truly see the thing grow
and breathe and start to have its own
energy and electricity at this Festival
was like truly the perfect place
and this is my second time that on
purpose I hadn't seen the film because I
wanted to experience it with the
Fantastic audience so I did that last
year with satanic Hispanics I'm like I
gotta do this again because you felt
everyone's energy and so watching our
our movie VHS 85 The Laughing the [__]
yes the Ooze
I was doing that with them yeah so it's
it's truly you you are here to be a fan
you're gonna get to experience it a
fantastic Fest is a very special place
but I have a feeling you're going to get
a very loud reaction at your next
Festival too yeah
here we go it's the same sick puppies
that Beyonce oh yes
it's gonna be a good time but in
particular like what you say about
fantastic Fest to actually feel it
firsthand now like it is incredibly
accurate and I have a feeling I will be
following in your footsteps and coming
back to this festival for years and
years huge congratulations on HS 85 it's
so good thank you you're not knowing no
at Beyond Fest keep an eye out for this
movie do not miss it I will guarantee
you you will love it